and fits grizzly is demar derozan making  the drive from southern california  there's the first field goal by Xion  williamson on the slab for us to come  out with anybody other than LeBron James  as good as the players were that  followed him Williamson inside like I  said many more to come that's number two  saw him get off the floor so little  again two men the game a little pocket  pass really good delivery on that a  giant does the rest  Baron sluttish  blew it inside Robinson tapped it out to  knock side  [Applause]  strength Kevin Knox looks like he's got  a chorister right away the teams that  had hopes of noise Kevin Durant Kyrie  Irving and others as Barrett he's a guy  that has made his way to New York via  the draft Barrett with the left hand  working against blue got to the bucket  encounter or maybe not okay  a situational sub they draw one up